foreign
to representative Lane
uh and and representative Ward what my
plan is for this document the way I see
it if we we have four if we all agree on
the content
uh and I know that that uh
representative Elaine and I do because I
Incorporated her changes from her
helpful review of it if we agree in the
content then my plan is to talk with our
research assistant Christina Dyer
but when I spoke with her back in June
said she would review the report to make
sure it was in the you know the
appropriate format
uh and in in drafting it I followed an
example she sent to me of a previous
commission report so I think it's
probably pretty close
and uh and when that's done
I'll submit it to the individual who
authorized this subcommittee our
election law chairman and member of this
subcommittee
representative rossbury that's my plan
my purpose in this meeting was to see if
we could actually take a vote and agree
that
we all well see if we all agree on the
content
I'll let you take a moment and
review it
you
I did make one change since the uh
the corrections I received from
representative Lane
it's on page three
it's uh
the portion that was highlighted in
yellow or I wasn't sure if we would have
a chance to have a meeting
I deleted that and altered the following
paragraph
it's basically saying we recommend but
using a few more words than just that
this is uh
it's on page three of the
annotated copy
one two three
oh and I did find one
typographical error on page four
under transparency enhancement I have a
number eight that's actually item nine I
didn't correct that when I inserted
oh found another typo
wow
because they're so rigorous about
exactly from something quotes but what
is meant to be quoted
yeah because I once directed a
philosopher I have never actually
you know
how to philosopher tell me I stand
correct
they argue their way well
either way we have a typo because I
think we need to be consistent so
I'm going to call the comma inside the
quote on expenditures the typo and we'll
fix that
including an individual
ancestors
well I'm I'm thinking that
I'm looking at as a list of quoted items
so I would say the comma goes outside
but we have one as long as it's
consistent and that's what I'm looking
for
English Style
no I'm not so are you telling me that
that the comma should be
well
have you been a copy editor
well I I am going to take the advice of
no I'm going to stick with my original
judgment I'm going to fix the one that's
different
here we go I'll fix the one that's
I hate I don't like typos I really to
test
all of them
okay so
if you care let's have an informal see
if we have a consensus here what's your
view on this representative Elaine
you don't care I
really don't care as long as they're
consistent well I have I have
reports on the Statue I have I have two
people I have two people here who care
and two of us who don't so I'll go with
the I'll uh respect the wishes of those
who care okay
so
good
okay would you say that again I've got
treasurer so
yeah okay I just said as far as the
general principles go I think we're
there I think it's more of a cleaning up
yep
and when you send it to
um
Christina Christina
okay I have one question I'd like your
okay on page three under structure of
report
the second paragraph
where it states following ideas and
suggestions and the next line down by
unanimous vote
should I
do we need to put in the actual vote no
it's four to zero the other two members
aren't here or can I just leave it as
unanimous vote
it was a unanimous vote of those of us
might be interested to know that the
Republican chair of the subcommittee the
ranking minority member
on the committee
where I'm at the same side yes okay so
can I like you would agree with just
leaving it as unanimous vote without
good
is there any other discussion needed do
so if someone would like to make a
okay
I'm gonna re record this I'll issue some
short minutes
okay
bear with me a moment okay move by
representative mirrorhead seconded by
representative Ward
if there's no further discussion I will
ask for a vote all in favor
say aye
representative Muirhead
aye
okay
and
that concludes the business I had
is there any other business anyone on
the subcommittee would like to discuss
how much fruit did we leave on the tree
I know that we we went for the really
low experience we went for the things
that were easy to not easy to fit that
think I covered that you may disagree
but I'm going to include the write-ups
that we got from
secretary Scanlon and attorney Fitch
and the
the job that the the write-up that uh
deputy secretary of state Aaron
Hennessey provided with us and the
write-up we got from the two
representatives from the Attorney
General's office I'm including those as
appendices
and for that very reason because I think
they captured a lot of useful things
that and I say that in the report that
they're they're worthwhile ideas we're
not endorsing them but they're
worthwhile ideas that contribute to the
discussion of how to improve the
campaign Finance system so I think I
covered that would you agree
yeah
okay
all right so if I was just say one thing
that I did is I put in an LSR right yep
for the one that I drafted that you that
representatively didn't want to be
included in because he hadn't had a
chance to really look at it and and it
was intended to catch those you know
just the things that we agreed on it was
not intended to
um to go further than things that that
we had but it was an extensive effort
and I don't know if I caught everything
so
um it I haven't gotten the LSR back yet
but when we do I I think we need I will
need to and others will need to go
through it very carefully because once
you start changing these definitions it
affects so many things different things
and even though I had this search you
know image search thing engine you can
search for the term
it's just hard to catch them all and
figure it figure it all out
and the one thing that we I don't think
that we did discuss was what we wanted
to do about the change and what the
Senate Finance or what what was in the
budget when they changed that to un
we didn't really talk about that or
whatever so I think you know I just left
it as it was in the LSR because we
hadn't really talked about it and I
thought when we get to it
when we have it before us in the
committee we can talk about what we want
to do because we never really I mean in
passing we talked to me we never reached
any consensus I don't think
we barely talked about it all but it
basically came very late I mean it was
early July when we did the budget and we
never really had a chance to talk about
it as a subcommittee
so so that I just want to let right now
that that's out there and when I get it
back from them I'll circulate it and and
let everybody look at it and
um and then we can kind of
see what we want to do with it whether
it's
but it was um
tedious
I think it's the word I did want to say
something to you no reason not to say it
in a public context that I do understand
and personally and and appreciate the
work you did on it and how much work it
was and my request not to be a a
co-sponsor was was exactly what you said
I just it's there were so many changes
in it I would need a considerable amount
of time to go through it and understand
all the implications maybe it's an
engineer thing I don't know but it's a
lawyer thing it's so that was the only
reason really and and the couple of
items where I had some disagreement that
you know that I mentioned uh I think
those could be resolved let's with more
discussion
uh so I
know I just want to make sure you
understand I really did appreciate it
and understand the work you put into it
I may be coming to Aaron
in the Secretary of State's office for
some help but uh because it's pretty
far-ranging and I I'm a really nervous
about unintended consequences and I then
that's really what
I was uh yeah kind of driven by
so okay okay
well if we have no other business then
I'll we'll conclude the meeting uh I do
want to say that I enjoyed working with
with
the other members of the subcommittee
I think we we did find
some areas of real agreement that were
bound to be some
right we've both been through the the
RSA 664 enough that we knew there were
areas we would you know agree on what
representative mirrorhead called the
low-hanging fruit but I think that's a
good place to start and it and it and
it's not the end of the process to spell
them out
and I also appreciated the interest we
saw from some members of the public
it's a
and it's it's good to know that there's
some interest out there
and also uh deputy secretary Hennessy
thank you very much for your
participation and your help in the work
that you did
uh drafting changes on 664 that was
tremendously helpful
all right well with that then uh I will
10 32
and I am not at this time planning
another meeting at the subcommittee
and I will reiterate I'm gonna
present this to our research assistant
Ms Christina Dyer to get her input on
the formatting and and and so forth
I will fix the typos that we mentioned
that we agreed to be fixed today before
I do that
and uh when done I'll present it to our
our election law chairman as
in his role as the person who instigated
the subcommittee
all right that's it I hereby adjourn the
meeting
well you did create a quorum and I'm I'm
which